[Music]
so
hi everyone good evening and welcome to
the table
on this sunny sunday my name is karen
miner
and i am so glad you're with us tonight
uh if you could take a moment
and comment down below let us know who
you are
where you're watching from um
we would love the opportunity to get to
say hello and welcome to you
personally in a few moments
you're going to see our worship team and
then
brett and you're going to notice
something different that hasn't happened
in
a little over a year they are going to
be
doing worship and the message from
pleasant valley united methodist church
which
is our church home and uh
fear not you're not missing anything
nobody else is there except for them
and uh scott and gary running our tech
and sound and everything but what
they're doing is they are
doing a run through uh
from the church tonight just to make
sure that we can live stream
and run everything through uh smoothly
and anticipation for our first
in-person service that we're going to
have on april 11th
so tonight you know it's one step closer
to getting back together having
church as a church community together
again which we're all looking forward to
um i'll still be with you here on the
live stream tonight
um both now and then as we close out the
service
so as we get started tonight i just
wanted to let you know
about a few things coming up ways to get
connected
and uh contribute here at the table
um and they are all related to
holy week which today kicks off this is
palm sunday
and then friday is good friday and then
of course
uh one week from today is easter sunday
and we have something going on
for all three of these this coming week
so good friday service
that will be obviously on friday uh
because it's a friday night service and
a lot of us
work we are doing that service online at
7 pm
so just tune in right here either on
youtube or facebook
to catch that service at 7 00 pm this
coming friday
then we have our easter sunday service
and that is going to be an
outdoor in-person service
uh at 10 30 in the morning so please
note the time change
10 30 a.m you're gonna have to get up
and and actually put on
regular clothes get ready uh we're gonna
be meeting
downtown garland in garland square
again that's at 10 30 a.m there's plenty
of room
so there's lots of room to distance
anybody who would like to come
is welcome to you so you can invite
friends and family members
and uh all you need to bring
is your chair and your mask and
let's hope that the weather continues to
hold and that it's a beautiful morning
to gather
and just remember jesus on this easter
sunday i can't think of a better way to
celebrate jesus
uh than gathering together on a
beautiful day outside
um and then finally i mentioned earlier
we will be resuming
our in-person services the sunday
following easter which is uh sunday
april 11th
we'll be meeting at pleasant valley
united methodist church that's where
you'll see the worship team and brett in
a few minutes
and that is a smaller space
and so if you do plan to join us for
that service on the 11th
you'll need to reserve your spot in
advance
and to do that you'll need to reach out
to sarah
i believe she's going to post her email
address she can be reached at sarah
s-a-r-a at thetabletx.org
so you can shoot her an email let her
know if you're planning on coming
on 11th how many are going to be in your
party and that way we're able to
save room for you so please make sure to
do that sooner rather than later so we
can make sure to plan accordingly
to make sure we're all safely distanced
and prepared
for that service on the 11th so lots of
lots of really really cool things coming
up
that carry with them a measure of hope
and togetherness
some things that we just have not had
regular tastes of in quite some time
so as you're able i hope you'll be able
to join us for those things
so as we transition into worship
will you pray with me let's close our
eyes and bow our heads
jesus thank you for a new day
thank you for hope thank you for
um just your faithfulness over the past
year
the ways that we've seen you in ways and
small ways and miraculous ways
the ways you continue to allow us to
meet online
and to stay connected even during
really really challenging tough times
so god we give you praise we give you
glory
we center on you tonight and we remember
that
you hold everything in your hands you
see the end from the beginning
that you see greater and bigger than any
of us in our human minds can so god help
us to continue to trust in you
to continue to center on you and
to continue to just follow you
follow in the way of jesus his character
his humility his grace
and um yeah god i pray that
that as we seek you we would find you
god
in jesus name i pray amen
[Music]
hey guys we are so excited
to be in this room together tonight
i wish you were all with us um so this
is carter and tyler i cannot tell you
how much i have missed doing music with
other
musicians on our team it is a gift it is
so
life-giving um so thank you guys for
playing tonight and being here
we're gonna go ahead and get started so
i hope that you'll join in wherever
you're at
[Music]
no place i'd rather be
no
[Music]
i
i want more of you guys
[Music]
there's no place i'd rather be
there's no place i'd rather be than
hearing your love here in your love
no place there's
[Music]
then i
i i want more of you
[Music]
let's sing out we love you
we love you
and we'll never stop we can't live
without you
jesus we love
you and we can't get enough
all this is for you
jesus we love
you
[Music]
we love you
we can't get
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus
[Music]
come on
that i can't contain we'll never stop
we can't live without you
jesus please
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus
let's sing come and consume
come and consume god oh we are we give
you permission our hearts are yours we
want you
we want you
to come and consume god oh we are
we give you permission our hearts are
yours we want you
oh we want you
sing that again come and consume god oh
we are we give you permission our hearts
are yours we want you
we want you yes god
to come and consume god all we are
we give you permission our hearts are
[Music]
yours
we love you
and we'll never stop we can't
live without you jesus
we love you oh god we can't get stuff
oh this is for you
[Music]
jesus oh
jesus
[Applause]
come set a fire jesus
[Music]
i have decided
to follow jesus
to follow jesus i
have decided
to follow jesus
no turning back
[Music]
no
still i will follow
[Music]
[Laughter]
though
[Music]
not
yes god
we're so grateful
[Music]
for the work that you've been doing in
us
over this past year and as this season
draws to a close and we start to
transition
into a new season i ask god that we
would continue
to pursue your ways and your work in our
life
that we would continue to invite you in
to our space
to invite others into our space god
that we would be your hands and feet
whether we're in isolation
or in community that we would be the
love of
god here present on this earth
[Music]
thank you so much for your grace
for your goodness and for each other
god set that fire at the table
would it be a fire of love and beauty
that touches this community in a real
and transformational way
[Music]
it's in your name that we pray amen
thank you team thank you thank you
and uh everyone welcome to the table
it's really really good to be with you
and
um i'm like mindy mentioned i'm really
glad to be back in this space
uh though i do miss you and i'm i'm very
excited about just the coming weeks
you know it's like um this isn't over
you know the pandemic isn't over
but um it does feel like at least
there's kind of a new chapter starting
um here at the table and that's um
that's encouraging you know just to be
back um and uh here and i will see many
of you at easter
and then slowly you know through the
weeks and months as as you guys
start to feel comfortable and we
re-engage here um i think that'll be
really really beautiful so
um yeah so tonight uh hopefully we
haven't had too many
um kind of technical issues i don't know
how all that went but i mean it sounded
nice here i thought it sounded really
good
um so uh thank you to scott and gary for
all their work
on the tech side of things they're
trying to work all the miracles
so i'm really grateful for them and
and all we had a number of ministry team
leaders here tonight they're just kind
of getting ready
kind of seeing the space figuring out
art processes and things like that so
um at any rate thank you uh to all of
those they know who they are so
um all right so tonight um
we are this is part six in our series uh
titled lent
from repentance to renewal and
uh uh today is is palm sunday uh and so
this is it's it's a fascinating day kind
of in church history
and in the story of jesus um because on
the one hand
um palm sunday is a i mean it's it's
kind of a day of celebration if if
you'll recall we'll read the story in
just a moment
um but the story of christ is that he
enters jerusalem
and the crowds at that time it's like
the adoring crowds they
lay palm branches thus palm sunday
and you can see some of the palm
branches in the background
here we got some palm branches and then
i see lily mae she's back here
uh and she's got her palm branch so uh
so that's kind of the that's the theme
and uh so it's it's kind of in a way
it's a time of celebration there you
know the crowds are they're chanting
hosanna which means basically god saves
or
um the lord saves and so it's
it's happy it's like this amazing
celebratory moment and yet
there's if you know the rest of the
story there is a little bit of like a
sense of foreboding
because you know just a week later or a
little less than a week what those same
crowds will be chanting then
which won't be hosanna uh but instead
crucify him so there's there's kind of
um
a little bit of um kind of a mixed
feeling you know there's a sense of that
foreboding as we
um kind of go into palm sunday and then
from palm sunday into
to holy week so um
[Music]
where i'm going tonight that the title
of my message this evening
is it's a question and it's what are you
writing what are you writing
um i think it will make more sense as we
get into our two scripture readings here
so the first one
uh is very short it's a prophecy from
the book of uh zechariah chapter nine
uh verse nine and uh this is uh
written by the prophet zechariah many
probably a few hundred years before
christ
though the way you know christians have
read this text down to the centuries
it's kind of hard to miss the connection
between this and then our second passage
which is mark chapter 11 which we'll get
to
right after that so um let's start with
zechariah chapter 9 verse 9
it says this rejoice greatly daughter
zion
shout daughter jerusalem see
your king comes to you righteous
and victorious lowly in writing
on a donkey on a cult the full
of a donkey and then mark chapter 11
verses 1-11 as they approached jerusalem
and they came to bethpage and bethany at
the mount of olives
jesus sent two of his disciples saying
to them
go to the village ahead of you and just
as you enter it you will find
a cult tied there which no one has ever
ridden untie it and bring it here
if anyone asks you why are you doing
this say the lord needs it
and will send it back here shortly so
they went and they found a cult outside
in the street tied at a doorway
as they untied it some people standing
there asked
what are you doing untying that cult
they answered as jesus had told them to
and the people let them go
verse 7 when they brought the cult to
jesus and
uh threw their cloaks over it he sat on
it
many people spread their cloaks on the
road
while others spread branches they had
cut in the fields
those who went ahead and those who
followed shouted
hosanna blessed is he who comes in the
name of the lord
blessed is the coming kingdom of our
father david
hosanna in the highest heaven so jesus
entered jerusalem
and went into the temple courts he
looked around at everything
but since it was already late he went
out to bethany with
the 12. okay so that's the story
and uh what i want to to name tonight
uh is something that i find just really
really profound and beautiful in this uh
text so to kind of set this up so jesus
is
about to enter jerusalem and he's doing
this both
because it was the jewish passover
which is this this kind of memorial this
day of remembrance
and but he's also doing it because as
he's hinted throughout the gospel of
mark
he knows what is to come he knows that
the cross
is is um kind of his next step
in his journey so he enters jerusalem
with this kind of dual purpose
um in mind and so basically jesus they
they make their way towards jerusalem
but bethany because you'll notice in the
story it says he went to bethany first
but i think he's about two miles outside
of jerusalem so they have this stop
that's when he tells the disciples go uh
and and basically you can see that he's
kind of planning his
entrance a little bit right and so he
tells them to
to get this this cult this um this
donkey
and uh what what i think is so
interesting
is that i mean if you think of like all
of the ways he could have entered
and what he could have ridden like this
is such an
interesting decision like because on the
one hand
it's pretty clear he's not being mousy
about his entrance right he doesn't just
walk in or doesn't say and he slipped in
through the back way into the city you
know that's that's not why there's
there's kind of a certain pageantry and
fanfare that he's
apparently accepting uh which we'll talk
about a little bit later that kind of
ties in with the zechariah passage of
you
your king is coming victorious right so
he's not coming in a mousy way
um and yet what he chooses to ride
is so interesting because he chooses
to ride this donkey
and and and so what i what i want you to
just kind of capture is like
this is the king of kings and the lord
of lords
this is the jesus who will soon spread
his arms
wide on a cross and carry
not just like me or you but like all of
humanity's
sin and shame and violence and he's
going to
bear that and then conquer it on the
cross
this is the jesus who will soon be not
only the crucified one but then the
resurrected
and ascended one and so that
jesus enters jerusalem
riding on a donkey
um now i get we're like modern people we
mostly drive cars
maybe i'm like playing this up and
you're like so what
um so here's maybe let me come at it
from a different angle
uh when a roman emperor entered
a city do you
do you think they wrote a donkey
let me go ahead and answer that um no no
they did not
uh and said what did a roman emperor or
a conquering king
at that time how did they enter the city
they found the biggest baddest
war horse they could find and they
rode in with all the pageantry into the
city and
and think about it what does a war horse
what does that
um like what does that communicate
because you can think of it
right all of um politics it's all optics
you know it's sort of like it's like
saying something without saying
something you want your
like you want to not only speak a
message but you you kind of want to look
the part
as well right so so a roman emperor when
they
ride in on a giant war horse like in
full you know armor sword like
what is that saying and think if you've
ever seen uh like those giant i'm
thinking this is random not i'm going
off script now
i'm thinking of the budweiser horses is
that tacky maybe that's tacky to talk
about in church
so but like you know those giant claws
clydesdales oh they're called yeah okay
good
so this is nice better without a screen
i have actual feedback so i'm not making
a fool of myself okay clydesdales right
like
a giant horse right what does that kind
of communicate
i am up here and you
peons you are down there right that's
what it
it kind of communicates i am a powerful
person
and you the emperors are saying you are
less powerful i am a somebody
and all of you are the
nobodies right this is this is what a
roman emperor as they
entered in this way this is what they're
communicating
and so here comes jesus
riding on a donkey
like what is going on here well here's
my
here's my big idea for tonight that the
stronger
the stronger you are on the inside
the less you have to project power
and status and success
on the outside the stronger you are on
the inside
the the less you have to project this
sense of power
status um success kind of pump and
circumstance and i am a somebody i'm a
somebody look at me like
that in other words we could reverse it
right the more you have to do that
the more you have to play out like look
at me i'm great like the more you have
to do that
we all sort of intuitively know oh gosh
oh are you really insecure
is that kind of is that what's going on
you know it's because
the the weaker you are on the inside
then the more
you have to project the more you have to
do that which is why what i want to
contend tonight
is that although it looks it might
appear
to the untrained eye that that the the
roman emperor or conquering king
riding in on their awesome war horse
like they're the cool one
they're the powerful one they've got it
going on what i want to actually contend
is that it's jesus riding in on a donkey
who is actually the powerful one who is
actually the secure one the confident
one and i think there's something in
that for us um
to learn as well you know because if you
think about it we can kind of take this
principle and start to look at
life and apply it in a number like a
number of different
arenas um so i'm a parent this is often
on my mind right if
a parent who finds themselves yelling
all the time um that's a bad sign
that doesn't actually mean like yeah i'm
so powerful i'm yelling to try to get
someone to do something
that's a bad like you gotta kind of pick
your moments as a parent
but if you're chronically yelling that
shows not how strong you are or like wow
what a powerful parent
no that shows what how weak you are
like and eventually the kid just tunes
you out like hey don't worry he always
does this
right so you can think parenting um you
can think of like leadership like a boss
right someone who's constantly barking
orders
someone who's constantly reminding you
about their title
um that's not leadership that's called
having a position
right but but if you're a leader and
you're having to constantly remind
people how important you are ah that's a
real bad
sign right if you're in a sense jumping
on that war horse all the time that's a
bad sign
i think another kind of example from
life
is maybe the best one is a bully like if
you think of
like a bully on the outside you'd think
oh wow
oh that true power they are so strong
they're
but what do we know about a bully a
bully becomes
a bully because they are afraid a bully
becomes a bully
because they don't feel good about
themselves on the inside because they
are insecure
otherwise they pick on their peers but
what does a bully do they
pick on someone weaker than themselves
right it's this sense of i have to
build myself up by pushing someone
else down um in 2015
i was uh i was basically helping in a
youth ministry at the
the last church um that i worked at and
so
uh i i was there and i remember i mean
it was kind of cool i'd done youth
ministry back in the day so i had some
experience and i loved like teens and
stuff
um but i remember there's one kid i'll
um i'll just call him cody
and uh cody was just a straight
up bully like this kid it was rough
um i remember uh like just kind of the
way he interacted like it was he was
kind of one of those kids
in um youth mission we used to call them
like egrs
you all heard this term extra grace
required
that kind of person you know like i
would see him walk through the doors i'd
be like
okay all right oh just sort of like a
little quick little breath prayer like
okay
jesus i need to be strong and yet
somehow i need to communicate
love and not pure judgment of this kid
because
this was a thing like he would i mean
not only he was um like he was a fighter
he's not only bully but just he was
physical he was kind of just
genetically he was a big kid like not so
tall but just strong
i mean stout and so he was constantly
getting in fights that was like i guess
his love language
it was some physical touch gone wrong or
something so he's
cramming he's fighting with kids and
then like younger kids so he was in high
school so he would pick
and like bully junior high kids uh and
then
make incredibly rude comments to all the
adult leaders
um nasty comments to all the girls i
mean
it was bad y'all like this kid it was
he's a bit of a nightmare and
uh so i finally i went to the youth
pastor at that time jake
and i just said like bro
what is going on who what is the story
here like what
what the heck is up and so
he sat me down after group and he
started to tell me the story
and i won't go into all the details but
suffice it to say
he was basically abused physically
abused
by his father and then neglected for
most of his life by
his mother they eventually divorced and
they kind of tried to go back and forth
but they were just constantly
kicking him out you know from one place
because he because over time this
this sort of rage just built up
inside him until he was just
completely out of control i remember a
few
years after that because that was 2015.
a few years later
i'm in my house when i hear a knock on
the door and it's cody
and i'm like hey man and
he was basically going around just
asking for odd jobs
trying to make money he was kicked out
of his house again and it was
it was really interesting because both
at that moment when he knocked on the
door but even
before that when i heard the story
behind the story so to speak
it was like i started to see him through
such a different lens
because i realized that all of that kind
of
macho i mean i remember how cody walked
like he didn't walk
he sauntered i mean like he owned the
place
just chest out i mean it was almost
cartoonish
the way he just kind of i remember
that's how he would like greet like
so like just wouldn't even use word you
know i was like come on man
but but i started all of a sudden i saw
it through such a different lens
because i realized he actually wasn't
full of himself in the sense of thinking
he's better than everyone actually deep
down
he was terribly afraid and insecure
and as he's there kind of asking me to
like
mow my lawn so he can get some money
i just realized looking at him how how
afraid
insecure and really ultimately
unprepared
for life that he was
you see the the weaker you are
on the inside the more
you overcompensate the more you project
this sense and it's different ways for
different people right for bullies it's
that sense of
power for someone else it's kind of
projecting that perfect
life for others it's that you know
success like whatever
our path is but we just start doing this
projection
thing which is why though
jesus didn't enter jerusalem
on a donkey because he was weak jesus
entered jerusalem on a donkey
humbly because he was strong
jesus wasn't humble because he was weak
jesus was humble
because he was strong jesus wasn't a
servant leader
someone who empowered and lifted up
others and elevated others he didn't do
that
because he was mousy and insecure and
like i don't know if i can do it maybe
you should try like that's not why he's
doing that that's not why his ministry
was characterized by that he was a
capable person
but he did that because he loved well
and because he was secure
in who the father said that he was
right jesus jesus was um
had that sense of love in that sense of
knowing himself
being okay with himself on the inside
that allowed him
to stop all of the pomp and the
circumstance and
not have to go down that road of the
outside this is
one reason to come back to that prophecy
by zachariah that i love it
because on the one hand zachariah again
makes it clear
this is the king this is the victor how
does zach write what he said see your
king comes to you
righteous and victorious
so so he's he's not saying the the king
will come
as a um as someone deeply insecure and
afraid
you know you're a loser like no
zechariah is clear he's going to come
as the righteous and victorious one and
yet
how jesus arrives communicates the
values of the kingdom
correct love service humility
in other words lowly in writing on a
donkey
it communicates something okay
so if you consider yourself a christian
uh here's the question i'd like all of
us to kind of reflect on
tonight where has my own
insecurity been pushing me
to ride war horses rather than donkeys
where has my own insecurity been pushing
me to ride war horses rather than
donkeys
in other words um where has my own
sense of of not feeling so good
on the inside been been kind of nudging
me
towards at best kind of foolish
at worst incredibly um
hurtful downright stupid ego driven
decisions on the outside
um where where is this happening in our
life and of course
as i've kind of alluded to this can play
out in many different arenas it's
different for every person
so this can happen as as a leader as an
employee
who can't follow a leader as um as a
parent
as a student as a son or a daughter like
this
at whatever season of life you're in we
this can happen to any of us
where when we're not feeling good on the
inside we start to project so that's
kind of the
question i want you to sit with um let
me give a few kind of tangible examples
of this that might get your wheels
turning um reflect for a minute on
what do you post on social media
what do i post on social media and why
do i post it right uh
now this is kind of different angles for
different people like the a really
common
kind of challenge with social media is
that i mean on the one hand we want to
kind of put our best foot forward right
it's a
sort of like the town square and you
know you're maybe not going to dress
like a slob or whatever like okay i get
it
but there there's kind of a line right
that we cross
it's and it's strange it's easier to see
it in others often than it is ourselves
like we can kind of tell when others are
like well that's not their life
that's not who they right you can kind
of see especially maybe your close
friends or something
but but what about for yourself like are
you kind of projecting are you jumping
on the war horse so to speak
projecting a certain sense of like oh
yes
i've got the perfect life the perfect
look another vacation for me
you know like what's what's your kind of
timeline what does it
look like and how accurate is it to
like your true self you know who who are
you really
inside is that like showing up or is it
this sort of false
person that maybe even like your best
friend would be like
what are you doing what is that's not
you if that's that's a
red flag if your family or friends
aren't recognizing the person in your
timeline it's probably not a
you know might consider is your own
insecurity kind of pushing you to ride
war horses
rather than donkeys um what about crazy
purchases
this is kind of budgeting you know why
what what what kind of clothes maybe the
car you can't afford
the house you can't afford what's
happening
there what what's going on with these
purchases and
is this a way where kind of like the
emperor of rome you're trying to
make your you don't feel maybe so good
on the inside so there's this sense of
projecting to the world i'm awesome i'm
a success
even though you maybe can't actually
afford it it's all on credit
um that's it's something to consider uh
what about
um kind of the obsession and culture
with our bodies
and kind of being the perfect having the
perfect body
um i think this is this is a particular
issue
um uh for like teens specifically teen
girls
um but honestly i think a lot of that
social media is kind of back to point
number one social media drives
a lot of that there's so much comparison
right you're comparing yourself to like
the
0.1 or 0.01 most beautiful people on the
planet
and then like oh man i'm terrible you
know this is a real problem
but honestly it's not just teen girls um
it's like all of us i remember
um uh just a few months ago i had this
moment with my son
uh dax where he um he's like he's a thin
fellow and so and you know pretty
athletic and so he like pulls up his
shirt he's like in the bathroom he pulls
up a shirt
and he flexes his abs and he goes hey
dad
look at this and i was like
wow dude that's that's awesome man like
you're yeah you're strong and then he
laughs he does this cocky little laugh
he goes i was like
okay and he goes i've seen you
you have a one pack and i was like
he's like i got a six pack you got a
one-pack i think he just meant like just
kind of a little bull you know or
something i don't know what is
and all of a sudden no joke he's nine
and i felt insecure i was like what
i'm fine man no i didn't really cry
but it was this kind of moment of like a
little bit of like
feeling judged and feeling like well
okay i am getting older and this is
right um i'm just glad i didn't see an
advertisement for some ridiculous like
those infomercials
with the workout equipment that you
would never buy unless you just had that
moment
you're like yeah maybe that the abinador
or whatever the thing is you know
um right and i'm just glad because that
would have been a moment where i just
kind of jump on the war horse make a
stupid purchase because i
i don't know i have some void in my life
i'm pushing 40 or whatever whatever our
little crisis are
but right these are all moments where
our own insecurity
kind of starts pushing us to to just get
our priorities out of whack right i'm
not saying like
who cares about working i like obviously
be healthy oh that's fine
but but we've got to keep our priorities
straight we've got to and we've got to
ask the question
why am i doing what i'm doing
why am i doing what's what's motivating
me what's pushing me
um another one what about our reaction
to feedback
when someone gives us kind of
constructive or negative feedback
on maybe how we came across or something
you know how does that how does that
hit us i don't know about you that's
hard for me like in that moment
i really want to jump on the war horse i
want to get defensive i want to explain
it and all of a sudden it's kind of
i'm off you know the chest is coming out
like whoa who are you
um are we lowly are we humble are we
able to receive that feedback
uh what about preemptive rejection the
way
that we we reject people who we suspect
might be about to reject us and that
kind of makes
us feel insecure i don't think they like
me well okay
well i don't like them i've never liked
them they're not even a good person you
know we start doing
this kind of and again can you see how
it's driven by a certain
insecurity um what about our just my
refusal to do things beneath me
quote unquote beneath me this idea of
well i'm just
i'm beyond that i'm too good for that
would you is that is that a phrase you
think jesus would
would ever use the the man who entered
jerusalem on
a donkey and of course i could just keep
going on and on and on because the war
horses
in our life they're like all around us
um but let me just close let me just
close with this
um here's the thing when you feel good
on the inside
when you know that you know
that god loves you and when you
hear the father's voice saying this is
my beloved son
this is my beloved daughter and you have
this inner sense of
um just i'm okay
now you no longer need to
jump on the war horses of life so much
now you no longer need to project
this sense of perfect perfection
the perfect at least for me a perfect
church perfect family
perfect marriage purge is perfect right
it's like
stop bruh just be yourself
see i think if you've been wondering
like what does it mean to write a donkey
that metaphor in my life you know what
does that even look like
i mean yes it's humility yes it's you
know
being it's it's being humble and the
servant of all it's all those things but
also
at a core level it's just being
you right this is why i think jesus kind
of rode in on a donkey
it's not like it's overly embarrassing
it's just nothing special
right it's just normal like a merchant
riding into town
and he's just being himself i mean what
if the end of the spiritual life like we
work for
decades only to find that in the end
all god was asking us to be was just
ourselves
and isn't that like the hardest thing in
the
world i think that's that's a
such an interesting idea that maybe
that's
all god is asking from us
so in this season of lent i just want to
encourage you
um start being more a little bit more
reflective self-aware knowing
recognizing when you might be jumping on
the war horse
and let's leave that behind and let's
let's be a church community
uh that just rides more donkeys sound
good
cool all right let me pray for you lord
jesus
i i just i thank you for tonight
i thank you for this community and
just the chance for us not only to
worship you but just to hear again to
remember again
the type of savior the type of leader
the type of king that you are
the the one who wrote a donkey the lowly
one the humble
one and god may that call us up higher
higher to our true selves higher to to
the sense of just the person
you've called us to be and god may we
set aside
the pretense and the fake
in the phony
and may you
just transform us make us natural
help us to relax
to be our true selves
you do that work in us it's in the
powerful
life-changing name of jesus that i pray
amen
thanks brett we're going to sing
that last song one more time and the
verse that really stood out to me
considering what brett was talking about
this week
was that line though none go with me
still i will follow
because sometimes um following the way
of jesus
is not necessarily the popular way it's
not the
the way that's going to always get us to
the front of the line
or um you know
it can be unfancy and
um sometimes just
put you in the crowd that's not gonna
get all the attention um
but there's so much depth
in that way um
and so i just want us to go through that
song and kind of reflect on what he's
talking about and
take inventory of where we're at and
where we're
deriving our identity who we are in him
and um kind of make that decision again
if you want to
of choosing to follow jesus
not necessarily as you know one decision
that covers the rest of your life but as
a
daily decision like today i choose his
ways
i choose to follow him
regardless of what that means for my
reputation
[Music]
regardless of what accolades i get but
just because
he is the most true thing that i could
possibly run after
[Music]
i have decided
to follow jesus
no turning back
[Music]
the world behind me
the cross before me
no turning back
[Applause]
i will
[Music]
i will follow
you
[Music]
i will follow you
i will will follow
[Music]
you
still i will not go
still i will follow
no turning back
[Music]
thank you guys
thanks worship team for that and thank
you brett for that message
so so um relevant and important
especially
right now um and you know as brett was
was talking i kept getting reminded of
that
passage in philippians 2 where it talks
about imitating christ's humility
and it says our attitude should be the
same as that of christ jesus
who being in very nature god did not
consider equality with god
something to grasp but made himself
nothing
taking the very nurture nature of a
servant
being made in human likeness and being
found in appearances of man
he humbled himself and became obedient
to death
even death on a cross therefore god
exalted him to the highest place
and gave him the name that is of every
name
that at the name of jesus every knee
should bow
in heaven and on earth and under the
earth
and every tongue confess that jesus
christ is lord
to the glory of god the father that's
that's the holy week story
so as you go into your week
i want to leave you with benediction
you are a child of god
this is true on your best days and on
your worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only one you nothing
about you is a mistake and this world
needs you being fully yourself authentic
and free so as you go into the week
ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend
these same gifts of unconditional love
and grace
to everyone you come in contact with
i hope you have a great week i hope to
see you online
this friday for our good friday service
at 7 pm
right here on facebook and youtube and i
also hope to see you
in person at our sunday serve easter
sunday service at 10 30 a.m in garland
at the garland square
and then the following sunday on the
11th
that will be our first in-person service
back at pleasant valley where brad and
the worship team were tonight
so remember if you do want to join us
for that first in person service you
need to reserve your spot
and you can reach out to sarah her email
is in the comments
you can reach out to her in order to
reserve your spot
so i hope you all are blessed go in
peace
and have a great week bye
you